c'est lors du second débat de ce sens
public consacré aux professeurs à nos
professeurs sous la menace terroriste 3
ans après l'assassinat de Samuel pati un
autre enseignant a été poignardé vous le
savez vendredi par un tuur au profil
similaire un jeune musulman venu du
Caucase abreuvé de propagande de l'État
islamique au point de passer à l'acte
avant de débattre de la sécurité dans
les écoles des pressions que les
professeurs subissent parfois aussi sur
le contenu de leur enseignement on
détaille ce que l'on sait du terroriste
d' ras avec Fabien RER Mohamed m avait
prêté allégance à daesh avant de passer
à l'acte une vidéo de revendication
ainsi qu'un enregistrement audio ont été
retrouvé dans son téléphone dans cet
enregistrement
audio Mohamed
m après avoir prêté serment à l'émire de
l'État
islamique développer sa haine de la
France des Français de la démocratie et
de l'enseignement dont il avait
bénéficié en plus des motivations de
l'assaillant l'enquête a permis de
retracer le déroulé précis de la matinée
du 13 octobre à 8h57 Mohamed m achète un
téléphone dans une grande surface avant
de prendre le bus et de se filmer devant
le monument au mort à
10h44 une caméra de surveillance le
filme aux abords du lycée Gambetta à 11h
il attaque mortellement le professeur
d'histoire Dominique Bernard bilan un
mort et trois personnes blessées dont le
pronostic vital n'est désormais plus
engagé en plus de la mise en examen de
Mohamed m le parquet a requis celle de
son frère tous deux sont placés en
détention provisoire il est apparu que
son jeune frère mineur âgé de 16 ans
avait pu lui apporter un certain soutien
dans son projet
mortifère conscient de la radicalisation
de Mohamed m il aurait notamment délivré
les conseils sur le manimement des
couteaux également dans le viseur de l'
qu un jeune cousin de Mohamed m suspecté
d'avoir été au courant du projet
d'attentat les obsèques de Dominique
Bernard sont prévus jeudi matin à la
cathédrale d'aras en présence d'Emmanuel
Macron les professeurs les écoles sous
la menace islamiste c'est le thème de
notre débat avec Sophie ventit bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur de
sciences économiques et sociales
secrétaire général du SNES FSU syndicat
majoritaire dans le second degré Ismaël
ferrade bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
professeur des universit à Paris nanire
chargé de mission laïcité à l'Institut
National Supérieur du professorat et de
l'éducation de l'académie de Versailles
et membre du laboratoire du centre de
recherche éducation et formation Max
Brisson bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes inspecteur général de
l'Éducation nationale vous étier
sénateur LR des Pyrénées Atlantiques qui
est membre de cette commission d'enquête
du signalement et du traitement des
pressions menaces et agressions dont les
enseignants sont victimes vous avez
auditionné cet après-midi la sœur l'une
des sœurs de Samuel paatti ETTI crupa
évidemment est resté à mes côtés pour
ouvrir notre débat je vous propose un
premier témoignage on va écouter
ensemble le maire de conflan
saint-onorine c'était hier lors d'un
hommage à à Samuel paatti 3 ans après
son assassinat Laurent brosse évidemment
face au spectre du terrorisme de retour
dans nos écoles regardez vers l'avenir
alors que la République est une nouvelle
fois à l'épreuve de la souffrance et de
la barbarie avec l'assassinat de
Dominique Bernard professeur de lettre à
haras
l'horreur a frappé à nouveau la
communauté éducative l'orreur a frappé à
nouveau la France et rappelle de
douloureux souvenirs ici à conflance
saint-honorine Sophie vintité pourquoi
ces terroristes qui sont nourris de la
propagande de de daesh en veulent à ce
point au professeur qu'est-ce que vous
symbolisez finalement pour eux ben
finalement les l'école publique en tout
cas l'école publique française c'est
l'école qui apprend à grandir ensemble
c'est l'école qui apprend à s'émanciper
par les savoirs c'est l'école qui
apprend à s'ouvrir vers l'extérieur
c'est l'école qui apprend à penser par
soi-même et on sait que tout ça c'est ce
que détestent les obscurantistes de tout
bord en particulier les terroristes
islamistes et donc à partir de là on
devient une cible et moi c'est c'est
beaucoup ce que j'ai entendu ces
derniers jours chez chez des collègues
c'est le sentiment avec la répétition
des des attaques contre les professeurs
et même d'assassinat de professeurs que
l'école est devenue une cible pour ce
qu'elle représente parce qu'elle
représente cette pation que certains
détestent mais que nous on va continuer
à faire vivre coûte que coûte l'islam
radical l'avait déjà écrit he DAEs l'a
écrit mot pour mot dans le journal
puisqu'ils ont leur organe de presse ça
a été écrit par les islamistes l'école
de la République française est une cible
en tout cas nous c'est c'est c'est une
expression qu'on a beaucoup entendu chez
les collègues hier matin notamment quand
on a échangé pendant les les 2 heures
qui nous ont été accordées et et on sait
enfin voilà on sait quel est le cœur de
notre métier c'est de transmettre des
choses aux élèves c'est de les ouvrir
vers l'extérieur et vraiment j'insiste
de les émanciper par le savoir et ça on
sait que bah que ça ça déplait à
certains on va on va on peut lister un
certain n de valeurs mais parmi ces
valeurs Ismael ferat il y en a une qui
est quand même très spécifique à la
France c'est la laïcité est-ce que c'est
l'une des valeurs ciblées à Oni par par
les propagandistes de daesh qui on le
sait maintenant on a eu le profil de du
du tueur d' race voilà sont rentrés dans
le cerveau de certains d'entre eux quoi
alors ce qu'on peut souligner c'est que
des pays européens qui sont pas
forcément là qu' est visé par le
terrorisme Islamist donc l'islamisme
radical cible en fait les démocraties
libérales quel qu'elle soit et quels que
soient les modèles mais est-ce que la la
laité entre guillemets est pardon nous
interrompre est un facteur aggravant
alors on va dire le système là je
rejoins ce que disait ma collègue le le
système scolaire euh public français et
depuis les depuis un siècle donc depuis
l'émergence des Frères musulmans à la
fin des années 1920 une cible spécifique
pour les islamistes parce qu'il
considèrent que c'est un
instrument en quelque sorte du modèle
occidental et donc il y a une
détestation spécifique de l'école
publique et en particulier du modèle
français qui avait beaucoup influencé
les élites musulmanes progressistes en
Égypte en Turquie en Iran et donc il y a
l'identification de l'école à la
française comme étant spécifiquement un
etemi alors soit subvertir soit à battre
et c'est bien pour ceci d'ailleurs he
que les mouvements islamistes lorsqu'ils
ont mené des actions très violentes on
peut penser à la guerre civile d'Algérie
ont particulièrement visé les
enseignants on sait que les enseignants
algériens ont payé un lourd tribut au
GIA notamment et donc il y a une
continuité historique hein de de
détestation profonde du système éducatif
occidental en règle générale et français
en particulier on peut citer ces valeurs
on a parlé de laïcité vous avez parlé de
l'émancipation on pourrait dire le libre
arbitre la musique la mixité le dessin
bref je vais pas fa faire une liste le
le le l'initiation à la sexualité
évidemment Max Brisson est-ce que là ce
que vous nous décrivez c'est une forme
de guerre de de civilisation est-ce
qu'on a sous-estimé cette cet entrisme
mais le fait d'avoir été une cible que
l'école soit une cible depuis
longtemps je voudrais juste revenir sur
ce qui vient d'être dit peut-être la
différence avec les autres démocraties
c'est que chez nous la laïcité sans
faire de sémantique est plus qu'une
valeur c'est un principeoui inscrit dans
notre Constitution les valeurs ça peut
se débattre un principe inscrit dans la
Constitution ça s'impose à l'ensemble de
la société ou alors il faut que le
peuple souverain décide de changer la
constitution donc c'est un différence
avec les démocraties qui sont en effet
aussi attaqué pour les valeurs qu'elle
porte et que porte aussi la démocratie
française mais le supplément d'âme si je
dire de la République française c'est de
porter dans sa Constitution dans les
premiers articles le principe de la
laïcité et c'est l'école de la
République qui dans notre histoire dans
la construction de notre République a
été le vecteur de cette laïcité alors
que l'on nit pas pris garde qu'on se
soit pas rendu compte qu'il y avait une
véritable attaque en règle d'un système
totalitaire qui en plus comme toujours
dans les systèmes totalitaire annonce ce
qu'il fait et de manière extrêmement
froide et qui a eu que l'école et les
professeurs qui la servent soit une
cible particulière mais derrière les
professeurs qui servent et partir les
professeurs d'histoire géographie c'est
bien notre Constitution nos principes
notre l'organisation même de notre
démocratie y compris sa singularité
laïque
alors évidemment on va jouv un chapitre
sur on va essayer de d'évaluer ce que ce
que sont ces agressions ou ces menaces
c'est pas forcément facile parce qu'il y
a un peu de d'autocensure il y a des des
des menaces ou des agressions qui sont
pas forcément relevé bref on va on va en
discuter mais regardez cette article du
Parisien qui nous parle d'un
ressortissant algérien on est à pentin
vendredi dernier donc euh on est
quelques heures après le l'annonce de
l'assassinat de Dom Bernard à race cette
ce ressentis il menace de décapiter
l'instituteur de son enfant on est à la
sortie de l'école c'est donc un père de
famille qui a été placé en détention
provisoire en attendant d'être jugé ça
aura lieu le 13 décembre et en parlet
une demande de retrait de titre de
séjour devrait être effectué pour que
cet homme il est âgé de 38 ans soit
expulsé bon c'est un cas il y en a
malheureusement eu d'autre Sophie vinti
il y a régulièrement des remontées de de
menaces verbales ou d'agression est-ce
que vous vous pouvez l'évaluer ça alors
c'est difficile à évaluer en terme de en
terme de chiffr par contre des collègues
qui nous disent qu'il y a des menaces
qui peuvent exister à la rencontre et
notamment des menaces qui montent via
les réseaux sociaux c'est c'est une une
réalité l'année dernière on a eu
plusieurs cas de de collègues dont le
contenu des cours avait été mis sur les
réseaux sociaux et dénoncé par le groupe
parents vigilant le groupe
lié voilà mais c'est aussi c'est aussi
une réalité des cègues qui ont vu qui se
sont vu menacés par l'extrême droite
avec aussi après enfin leur leur
identité a été divulguée sur les réseaux
sociaux et ils ont reçu des menaces on a
des collègues qui ont dû vivre également
avec protection policière parce que la
fachosphère c'était s'en était aussi
pris à eux donc les menaces elles
viennent de toutes parts elles sont
elles sont bien réelles et ça pose
effectivement la question de la
protection des des personnels dans ce
contexte ouis euh le ministère de
l'Éducation j'essaie de trouver des des
éléments un peu pour évaluer cette
menace a recensé près de 180 incidents
lors de l'hommage qui était rendu hier à
Dominique Bernard le professeur de
lettrre d'aras 179 saisine du procureur
de la République pour être précis un
chiffre qu'on peut peut-être Ismaël
Ferrat mettre en relation avec les
intates à la laïcité j'essaie de pas
faire d'amalgame trop facile mais bon
puisque on essaie d'évaluer est-ce que
ces atteintes à la laïcité elles sont de
plus en plus nombreuses et quelle forme
ell prennent alors tout dépend comment
on compte c'est un peu le grand problème
donc là je parle sur le contrôle de la
commission d'enquête euh les remontées
ministérielles alors aujourd'hui on peut
déclarer hein c'est une réforme que
Jean-Michel Blancard a mis en place
durant l'année scolaire 2017-28 les
personnel peuvent déclarer eux-mêmes en
ligne librement ce qui est plutôt
positif les atteintes qu'ils peuvent
subir le problème c'est qu'il faut
connaître le site il faut savoir qu'on
peut déclarer et il faut en fin de
compte faire la démarche de déclarer
donc ces remontées ell varient au fait
entre quelques centaines on va dire un
milliers c'est grosso modo depuis 3 4
ans he les le le j'allais dire la la
fourchette c'est en fait ça dépend on a
commencé à le faire par semestre puis
maintenant on compte par mois donc c'est
vrai que ça dépend vraiment du du
comptage alors ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que lorsqu'on va faire des
sondages donc là les sondages
techniquement c'est un peu différent
mais lorsqu'on va interroger un
échantillon d'enseignants je par sous le
contrôle d'une enseignante de ses qui
sera je pense assez compétente pour
parler voilà des des limites des
sondages on se rend compte que les
sondages montrent que plus d'enseignants
déclarent avoir été confronté à des
contestations donc ça peut monter à
1/ers 40 50 voir une majorité au moins
une fois dans la carrière donc là on est
dans le déclaratif voilà dans le
déclaratif mais là pour le coup donc
tout dépend quel instrument on utilise
si on utilise les atintes à la Cité
remonté ministérielle on peut dire
quelques centaines de cas pour 10
millions d'élèves bon statistiquement
c'est pas grand-chose par contre si on
se base sur les sondages quand il y a
un/ers 40 50 % d'enseignants qui disent
j'ai été victime de contestation j'ai dû
me censurer j'ai dû éviter une partie du
programme là c'est quand même beaucoup
plus signifiant mais ça reste des
sondages donc c'est très compliqué de
d'avoir un point de vue j'allais dire
fondé que sur les sondages Max Brisson
le Sénat a donc décidé évidemment
c'était avant parceque la commission
d'enquête elle a été ouverte il y a
plusieurs mois avant l'assassinat de
Dominique Bernard haras d'ouvrir cette
commission sur les menaces et agressions
contre les les enseignants qu'est-ce que
vous cherchez qu'est-ce que approuver
d'éventuelles défaillances de l'État 3
ans après l'assassinat de de Samuel
Patti quelle est la la logique quelle
est votre démarche en fait dans la
commission d'enquête le notre objet est
de bien montrer en quoi le professeur
qui a été décapité assassiné a bien
obtenu ou pas la protection
l'encadrement l'accompagnement qui est
nécessaire pour tout agent de l'État
dans l'exercice en fonction et qui
puisit pour un professeur donc nous
verrons bien
l'enquête la commission d'enquête a
commencé à travailler avant l'été mais
il y a eu les élections sénatoriales
nous reprenons véritablement nos travaux
et je peux vous dire que cet après-midi
l'audition de de Madame Paty de la sœur
de Samuel Paty était parti exent
poignante un autre sujet ce sont les
atteintes à la laïcité oui et je pense
qu'il y a mission commission que la
commission de l'éducation de la culture
je le proposerai demain nous avons
réunion du bureau demain matin je
proposerai que à côté de la commission
d'enquête qui est liée à l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty il y a un véritable
recensement de la réalité des des
atteintes à laïcité on peut pas mettre
tout sur le même pied d'égalité là
lorsqu'on est sur la la commission
d'enquête Samuel paatti il s'agit
d'évoquer ce qui a conduit à un drame
absolu à la mort d'un professeur il y a
les multiples atteintes dans la vie
quotidienne des professeurs il y a la
manière dont la l'éducation nationale
les traite dont elles sont remontées
donc je crois qu'on a vraiment besoin
d'objectiver le
sujet ça sera une mission d'information
tout cas mon groupe va proposer demain
matin au bureau de la commission de
l'éducation de la culture du Sénat cette
mission d'information pour y voir plus
clair et peut-être aussi pour faire des
propositions sur la manière
d'accompagner les professeurs et
d'apporter une réponse je pense qu'il
manque véritablement aujourd'hui un
véritable plan de lutte contre toutes
les attêtes à lacité et contre
l'islamisme radical qui s'attaque à
l'école de République ouais et
effectivement ça ça ça me semble
important parce que si on ne connaît pas
exactement ce dont on parle c'est
difficile de lutter vous êtes d'accord
avec cette idée queon a on a peut-être
mis un peu ça sous le sous le tapis
pendant des années ben en tout cas euh
nous c'est pas on n' pas commencé à
dénoncer le pas de vague en 2023 c'est
quelque chose qu'on qu'on a pu pointer
ces ces dernières années et surtout le
fait que quand on quand on alertait sur
des collègues qui pouvaient être menacés
l'institution ne réagit pas tout de
suite et encore aujourd'hui des
collègues qui sont menacé pour par pour
diverses raisons par diverses personnes
et ben encore une fois et d'ailleurs on
a pu échanger avec le ministre ce matin
sur la question de la sécurisation et de
la protection des personnels et ben on
lui a dit mais aujourd'hui trop souvent
des collègues qui sont menacés et ben
ils n'ont pas immédiatement la réponse
de l'institution en terme de protection
en terme de protection fonctionnelle qui
est le dispositif juridique
d'accompagnement mais aussi en terme je
dirais d'accompagnement psychologique
parce que quand vous voyez menacer de
mort et que vous retrouvez tout seul
chez vous ben c'est quand même et que
vous savez que votre adresse circule
dans la nature c'est quand même un peu
compliqué et comment aujourd'hui en 2023
3 ans après l'assassinat de Samuel pati
on peut encore avoir une institution qui
met 5 6 7 8 jours 10 jours à répondre à
la demande de protection d'un d'un un
collègue donc ça c'est quand même en
tout cas ce qu'on a dit ce matin au
ministre euh il nous a dit que ça allait
faire partir en tout cas des éléments
qu'il allait qu'il allait étudier on lui
a quand même dit que nous ça fait
plusieurs années qu'on pointe cette
question du délai de réponse des
rectorats à des professeurs qui sont
menacés et au-delà du délai de réponse
c'est aussi qui traite la la question
moi j'ai le souvenir l'an dernier d'un
collègue en Normandie qui était menacé
de mort en raison du contenu de ces
cours qui avaient été pointés par par
parents vigilants et ben la pour la la
le rectorat avait mis beaucoup de temps
à apporter son soutien à apporter sa
protection et quand j'avais signalé le
cas au cabinet du du précédent ministre
on m'avait dit ah benah on est pas au
courant al j'aurais dit mais c'est quand
même un professeur qui est menacé de
mort donc ce matin on a dit au ministre
qui fait quoi qui a l'information et qui
gère mais on en est encore là en 2023
donc sur la protection des personnels il
va falloir aller enfin il va falloir
accélérer ouis et puis savoir qu'est-ce
qui est du domaine de l'urgence ou pas
aussi quand on quand on a gérer
j'imagine beaucoup de de de décisions et
de souciis vous vous parliez de
l'audition de la sœur de de Samuel Patti
je propose à Quentin calm de de nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
parce qu'on va grâce à lui écouter
plusieurs extraits de cette audition qui
effectivement était était émouvante
rebonsoir Quentin et qui s'est déroulé
dans une ambiance particulièrement
solennelleonsir ou tout à fait il y
avait un silence de plomb dans la salle
de la commission d'enquête cet
après-midi bien sûr Thomas car nous
sommes au lendemain de la commémoration
des 3 ans de l'assassinat du professeur
de conflan saint-onorine et 4 jours bien
sûr après la mort de Dominique Bernard
le professeur d' race avec des moments
particulièrement émouvants comme quand
Michael pti évoque le lendemain de la
mort de son frère écoutez qu'est-ce
qu'on devient après ça c'est bien cette
question que je me suis posée le
lendemain de sa mort il va bien falloir
que j'en fasse quelque chose de ce ça un
S sans nom juste un visuel à l'Institut
médico légal où ma réaction première a
été de dire ce n'est pas lui je crois
que je voulais pas que ce corps mortri
soit celui de mon frère ce ça inomable
ne prendrait sens que lors que j'aurais
eu toutes les vérités même celle dont je
n'aurais pas voulu qu'elle soit vraie en
règle générale nous choisissons nos
vérités mais dans certains cas on
observe que c'est pas nous qui
choisissons nos vérités mais ce sont les
vérités qui nous choisissent c'est ce
qui se passe quand certains veulent nous
imposer leur vérités celles qui sont
agréables et rassurantes pour eux pas
pour
moi voilà la sœur de Samuel pati qui a
été extrêmement marquée bien sûr par
l'attentat de 2020 elle a donc prononcé
un réquisitoire c'est ce qu'a dit un
sénateur PS en le saluant d'ailleurs
face aussi à certains manquements de
l'éducation nationale cela s'est vu à un
moment particulier à la question simple
est-ce que la mort de votre frère a
servi à quelque chose écoutez la
réponse alors est-ce que la mort de mon
frère a servi à quelque chose bon comme
vous le savez si ça vait serv à quelque
chose peut-être que Monsieur Dominique
Bernard ser serait encore là donc je
pense
qu'effectivement les mesures n'ont pas
du tout été prises puisque l'affaire de
mon frère n'a absolument pas été
analysée parce qu'il faut quand même
comprendre que ce qui arrivve à mon
frère on peut effectivement pointer des
responsabilités à droite à gauche mais
c'est surtout comprendre l'entrisme
islamique qui est à l'actuel dans nos
écoles et qui prend de plus en plus de
place cette entr islamique évidemment va
continuer dans d'en parler dans ce débat
mais Michel patiel a été également
critique VO très critique envers
certains ministres oui on retiendra à sa
charge envers papendille depuis octobre
2022 le ministère d'éducation nationale
publie le nombre d'atteintes à la
laïcité de façon mensuel porte de
vêtements ou de signes religieux la
lecture que faisait le ministre de ces
chiffres est problématique selon Michel
pati on écoute revenons maintenant sur
le comptage des attatements Suel à la
laïcité sans doute un terme pudique pour
ne pas parler d'offensive islamique
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur papendia pour
justifier ses chiffres préfère parler de
la culture du finalement afin de
minimiser la gravité du phénomène il
précise tout de même qu'il y aura deux
pics annuels l'un pendant le Ramadan et
un autre en octobre lié à l'attentat
contre mon frère ce qui confirme à
demi-mot qu'il s'agit bien de
revendication identitaire de la mouvance
islamiste monsieur papendia donne
également le ton il s'agit de phénomène
inéluctable auquel il faudra bien
s'habituer tout en se refusant
d'admettre que le nombre réel
d'atteintte à lacité est sous-évalué que
nombre de faits ne sont pas signalés et
qu'il y a une recrudesence depuis
l'attentat de mon frère à quoi à quoi
cela sert-il de jouer le jeu de la
transparence sans même reconnaître que
l'on â en nos troubles voilà Thomas un
témoignage fort dans une actual une
actualité bouleversante on tiendra aussi
cette phrase perdre l'école ce n'est pas
perdre une bataille ni offrir une prise
de guerre à l'adversaire c'est perdre la
guerre on verra ce qui ressort
maintenant des travaux de cette
commission d'enquête lancée en juin
dernier et dont le travail raisonne
particulièrement fort avec les
événements de ces derniers jours merci
beaucoup Quentin Sophie ventit est-ce
que vous employez vous aussi ce terme de
guerre est-ce que l'école est au centre
d'une d'une guerre et alors on on
parlera du fait que il y a effectivement
des extrémistes de différents bords mais
d'une guerre menée notamment par les
Frères musulmans cette volonté de
s'attaquer voilà au au symboles aux
valeurs de la de la République à travers
l'école je sais pas si je vais employer
le mot guerre en tout cas je sais que le
modèle de l'école dépl au aux
terroristes islamistes que les que les
terroristes islamistes détestent ce que
l'école publique porte que les les
valeurs les principes qu'on porte et
notamment moi j'insiste sur le côté la
façon dont dont notre école publique en
tout cas nous c'est comme ça qu'on
conçoit notre rôle d'enseignant c'est
vraiment d'élever les élèves c'est
vraiment de les de les faire grandir
ensemble et ça on sent bien que ça peut
rencontrer des des résistances des
oppositions on peut être attaqué pour ça
et être attaqué physiquement pour ça
mais pour autant on va pas arrêter de
faire ce qu'on fait ou voilà Ismaël
Ferrat je je reviens aussi sur un autre
élément une fort du du témoignage de de
Michael pati cet après-midi au Sénat
devant la commission d'enquête voilà
cette attaque contre l'ancien ministre
de l'éducation nationale gr ce qu'il dit
c'est qu'il a clairement cherché à à
sous-estimer la réalité des atteintes à
la laïcité vous qui êtes au cœur de ces
questions qu'est-ce que vous en dites
alors c'est compliqué parce qu'encore
une fois les les les atteintes en fait
ce sont des remontées de terrain donc en
fait les gens déclare donc on va pas le
ministère vont vouloir cacher hein le le
nombre d'atteintes qui est des déclarer
encore une fois le problème c'est qu'il
est probable que tout le monde ne
déclare pas en fait le problème il est
là en réalité c'est moins une volonté si
on incite les profs à déclarer ils vont
le faire plus spontanément vous voyez ce
que je veux dire alors que si on reprend
le pas de vague on se souvient de ce
hashtag pas de vague si au contraire
quand un prof signale B on a tendance à
lui dire bah non attend ça va pointer
notre établissement ne fait pas de vague
il y a clairement une impulsion à donner
de la part de ministre les atteintes les
atteintes elles sont déclarées elles
sont pas infiltrées par l'établissement
ça c'est important parce que c'est qu'il
y avait un vrai risque au fait les
établissements disent pas chez nous hein
enfin gros pas de vague ça pour le coup
dans le système qui était mis en place
par Jean-Michel Blanca et poursuivi par
papa Indias il a une grande continuité
de ce point de vue-l sur le sujet les
atteintes sont déclarées et une fois
qu'elles sont déclarées elles remontent
donc en fait dans tous les cas elles
sont connues il y a pas de de filtre le
problème à mon avis c'est aussi une
question de alors là je vais parler
comme chercheur pour le coup c'est une
question d'étiquetage une contestation
d'enseignement elle peut être liée à un
élève perturbateur ça on a T tous eu moi
j'étais en second degré on a tous eu et
tout eu en cours des élèves
perturbateurs est-ce que l'élèv
perturbateur il perturbe le cours parce
qu'il est perturbateur est-ce qu'il le
fait parce qu'il est dans une mauvaise
pass est-ce qu'il le fait parce qu'il
aime pas le coursou est-ce qu'il fait
pour des raisons religieuses parfois
c'est très compliqué par exemple on se
rend compte alors là je passe le
contrôle de monsieur le sénateur on se
rend compte que il y a plus de
déclarations de la part des enseignants
qui enseignent en Rep et plus en matière
de laïcité est-ce que c'est une question
de violence scolaire générale parce
qu'on sait qu'il y a des éissements très
dégradés hein faut pas se lurer il y a
des étaabissements qui sont très
violents par ailleurs et est-ce que ces
phénomènes de violence ne vont pas se
mélanger à des questions de de religion
de manière assez opportuniste avec les
élèves qui vont dire en gros je provoque
parce que je sais que ça va marcher donc
l'étiquetage il est compliqué et parfois
ce sont les enseignants qui qui le font
en disant est-ce que l'élève qui a
provoqué il le fait pour des raisons
religieuses ou pour des raisons de
perturbation j'allais dire classique
est-ce qu'il y a pas une une façon de
prendre les lèvres à part peut-être avec
l'enseignant avec avec à une personne
qui est spécialisée de discuter avec lui
de pouvoir déceler la cause réelle de ce
comportement ce qui ce qui est fait
certainement dans de nombreux cas ce qui
ce qui est fait alors on manque parfois
de temps mais nous quand on est face à
des à des contestations par exle sur de
la laïcité ou sur d'autres questions de
contenu d'enseignement déjà enfin on
s'aperçoit beaucoup ces dernières années
c'est que des élèves arrivent avec des
idées des idées fausses et des idées
reçues notamment sur sur la laïcité
parce qu'ils ont entendu des bribes de
débats entre guillemets ou de prise de
position des uns et des autres et ils
arrivent en disant la laïcité c'est ça
et on dit mais non c'est pas ça la la la
laïcité et quand on prend le temps c'est
une machine anti anti alors ça arrive
d'avoir des élèves qui nous disent bah
on a pu entendre des élèves qui nous
disent mais j'ai entendu j'ai vu sur
TikTok ou sur Instagram que la laïcité
c'était contre l'islam c'était contre
les religions et nous notre travail en
tant qu'enseignant c'est justement de
prendre le temps avec les élèves pour
leur dire non ce n'est pas ça voilà ce
que c'est que la laïcité et de et de
faire ce travail d'enseignement mais sur
le temps long mais j'ai tendance à
rappeler la laïcité ça se résume pas sur
un post Instagram alors que les élèves
c'est un peu ce qu'il voi et donc nous
notre travail si on nous en laisse le
temps et si on nous permet de le faire
dans une relative sérénité ce qui est
quand même pas toujours le cas et ben on
arrive à à faire ce qui est notre rôle
premier transmettre et émanciper Max
Brisson qu'est-ce que vous vous retenez
de l'audition de de Michael paatti
qu'est-ce qui vous a le le le plus
frappé d'abord très largement une partie
de notre débat se retrouver cet
après-midi dans lors de l'audition
d'abord oui il vous faut
systématiquement déclarer il n'est plus
possible qu'il y ait du pas de vague
vous dites qu'il n'y a pas de que le pas
de vague a disparu je voudrais vraiment
en être persuadé mais acceptons l'idée
que le le mécanisme mis en place doit
l'éviter après il y a tout
l'accompagnement et tout le traitement
quelle est la réponse et si on peut
reprocher quelque chose à l'ancien
ministre c'est que ces remontées
n'étaient pas faites pour être commenté
comme on commente les variations
saisonnières du chômage ça ressemblait
un peu à cela et c'était assez
désagréable il s'agit d'y apporter des
réponses des réponses individuelles au
cas par cas qui permettront d'ailleurs
de trier les réalités du contexte en
effet tout est perturbateur n'est pas en
soi quelqu'un qui peut qui porte
atteinte à la lcité et rendre un peu
plus publi aussi les sanctions parce
qu'on en a parlé tout à l'heure vous
voilà mais aussi les réponses alors les
réponses individuelles les réponses
collectives alors d'abord en effet le
mot qu'il faut aussi utiliser c'est
l'omot sanction c'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure j'ai indiqué que lacité elle ne
se discute pas on ne discute pas des
règles du vivre ensemble qui s'appelle
la Constitution alors on change la
Constitution mais c'est un combat
politique donc il faut d'abord rappeler
que comme d'autres formes de délitf
l'antisémitisme est de délit contester
la laïcité ne l'est pas mais en toutous
les cas c'est contesté la République
c'est contesté notre Constitution c'est
contesté notre vivre ensemble donc
d'abord poser les choses clairement et
sanctionner deuxièmement peut-être aussi
auprès des professeurs les réarmés
intellectuellement lorsque notre
République a porté la laïcité il y a
plus d'un siècle et demi aujourd'hui
dans les campagnes françaises les les
institut tuteur étit formé à cela ils
étaient armés intellectuellement pour
cela je doute aujourd'hui je dis devant
universitaire et je l'ai dit cet
après-midi que les inspect que
l'université a pris la mesure du sujet
et aujourd'hui que dans la formation des
professeurs la manière dont on les forme
et on les aide à porter le principe de
la laïcité le principe constitutionnel
de la licité et sa dimension singulière
à l'école publique je doute que cela
soit vraiment au cœur de cette formation
et si on veut un vrai plan de lutte
contre l'islamisme radical ces attaques
contre l'école il faudra bien s' donner
ces moyen là h sur la sécurité
maintenant Sophie vtit qu'est-ce qui a
été fait puce que effectivement voilà il
y a cette cette double actualité quoi
c'estàdire que Dominique Bernard est
assassiné quelques jours avant le 3e
anniversaire de de de la mort de de
Samuel Patti et donc forcément ben on on
en est à l'heure du bilan qu'est-ce qui
a été fait en matière de sécurité pour
améliorer la sécurité notamment à
rentrer les établissements pas
grand-chose voir rien puisque ces
derniers ces derniers jours nous on a eu
beaucoup de retours de collègues qui
nous ont dit mais en fait dans nos
établissements al ça va vous paraître
dérisoire mais je vais vous parler de ce
qui est la la réalité de nos
établissements la grille du parking des
professeurs qui reste ouverte 24 qui
reste ouverte pendant pendant 4 semaines
et n'importe qui peut entrer le trou
dans le grillage que les élèves
utilisent les élèves en retard utilisent
mais qui du coup est aussi une porte
d'entrée l'alarme anti-intrusion qui ne
fonctionne pas c'est ça la réalité de
nos établissements donc avant d'aller
sur des pseudo solutions type portique
et cetera qui d'ailleurs pose d'autres
problèmes déjà en tout cas nous c'est ce
qu'on a dit ce matin au ministre il faut
réparer ce qui existe notamment sur les
points d'entrée et les points de sortie
aujourd'hui ça ça peut-être vous
paraître dingue en 2023 mais il y a des
points d'entrée et de sortie dans de
très nombreux collèges et de lycées qui
bah qui sont ouverts à tous les vents
parce que ça a pas parce que les
collectivités territoriales n'ont pas
joué leur rôle de prise en charge du
bâti scolaire ouais alors et tiens
justement parmi les annonces du ministre
de l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui
Gabriel Atal il y a le lancement d'une
enquête flash auprès des chefs
d'établissement justement sur ces
questions
de de de sécurité Ismaël Ferrat c'est
c'est là aussi le c'est c'est compliqué
de trouver le le le le le bon le bon
niveau où on met le curseur parce qu'on
va pas transformmer toutes nos écoles en
en bunker on n'est pas aux États-Unis on
va pas commencer à armer enfin bon c'est
c'est quoi c'est plus de de caméas de
porti plus d'humains et alors la
question des moyens humains se posera
alors je me permets de rappeler que
Samuel paatti notre collègue a assassiné
en pleine rue donc au fait j'allais dire
c'est pas parce qu'on met des des grises
qui est nécessaires pas de pas
d'ambivalance d'ambigué sur le sujet
c'est pas parce qu'on met desgé que les
terroristes islamistes vont s'arrêter au
gris enfin je dire quelqu'un qui veut
tuer il va tuer non mais por ça peut
déceler la saillant ça aurait pu être
arrêté voilà en fait ça peut marcher
dans le cas de l'établissement scolaire
c'est vrai qu'en dehors ça règlera pas
la question qui est une question de
rassignement de police fondamentalement
oui mais déjà si on se sent plus
sécurisé à l'intérieur deéement c'est
après effectivement donc ça c'est
important de de sécuriser la véritable
question c'est quel moyen humain donc en
fait quel personnel quelle intervention
par exemple des des AED donc les
surveillants des des équipes mobiles de
sécurité qui peuvent intervenir en cas
de difficulté alors pas de de violence
extrême mais pour calmer les choses en
cas de de problème dansissement donc ça
il y a des moyens humains effectivement
mais encore une fois ça ne règle pas la
question de la menace qui pèe sur les
enseignants si les enseignants sont
menacés et ma collègue l'a rappelé sur
les réseaux sociaux ça déborde très
largement l'établissement vers leur vie
privée leur domicile leur fréquentation
leur lieux entre guillemets de
sociabilité sont parfois connus en ligne
et donc il y a un risque même en dehors
d'établissement qui ne sera pas
forcément réglé que par la
questionétablissement et donc on revient
à la question de la sanction Max Brisson
dans les autres annonces de de Gabri
aujourd'hui il y a notamment je je
rappelle ces incidents qui ont été
signalés 179 cisine du procureur de la
République lors de la minute de silence
de l'hommage rendu à à Dominique Bernard
le le le le professeur assassiné à haras
Gabriel Atal demande que dans les cas
les plus graves il y ait une exclusion
des élèves ce qui pose une autre
question c'estàd que je je sais qu'à
chaque fois prendre la décision
d'exclure un élève d'un établissement
c'est une décision très lourde parce que
finalement il sort de ce de de ce de
cette machine à essayer d'intégrer à
essayer de de d'apprendre le libre
arbitre et cetera c'est touj une
décision compliquée à prendre mais vous
dites il faut aller jusque là il faut
aller jusqu'aux sanctions çaà dire on
parle de deux choses totalement
différentes parle d'un côté d'assassin
de personnes qui va le tuer au nom de
leur idéologie mortifaire et là il
s'agit avant tout de problèm de police
problème de renseignement de lutte dans
tout le pays contre le terrorisme
islamiste et des moyens que l'on se
donne pour que ces terroristes pe puiss
pu
nuir il nuisent contre l'école mais il
nuisent aussi contre bien
sûr vous avez raison de son pas VI du
terrorisme islamiste même si on est plus
choqué lorsqu'il s'agit de professeurs
là c'était pendant l'hommage mais est-ce
que vous savez avait pardon vous
interrom il y avait la doctrine Juliani
à New York c'estàdire que le le premier
Briis de glace on sanctionne c'est pour
ça que je je fais ce lien parce que
est-ce qu'il faut être très sévère dès
le début la plus petite atteinte à la
lcité après il y a les atteintes en
effet à la laïcité les atteintes du
quotidien les aut les aut s sû de
certains professeurs parce ils ont des
difficultés à mener telle ou telle
partie du programme les provocations qui
peuvent être menées d'abord un il faut
faire confiance aux professeurs qui sont
quand même en capacité me semble-t-il
d'aborder d'aborder sujet il faut je le
disais tout à l'heure les les réarmer
leur donner les manières de répondre à
ces sujets d'apporter des informations
leur formation le permis mais pas tous
pas systématiquement je pense qu'il y a
un véritable plan à à mettre en œuvre
étant formation i qu'en formation
continue des professeurs face à ces
défis à ces défis à bas bruit très
souvent mais qui se multipli et qui
empoisonne la la vie de nos de nos
établissements après oui il y a aussi le
registre de la sanction alors elle est
pas elle doit être graduée mais elle
doit être elle doit exister et lorsque
les fautes sont graves il faut aussi
sanctionner nous avons lorsque les
fautes sont graves nous avons à faire à
ce moment-là à des élèves ou à des
parents qui sont toujours qui sont dans
des qui comprennent eux parfait aitement
ce qui est la lcité qui comprenent
parfaitement les règles notre République
mais qui veulent les défier qui veulent
les repousser les rejeter les combattre
je crois qu'il faut faire la différence
entre un jeune qui est dans la
provocation et qui rébette
maladroitement ce qu'il a pu entendre et
ça c'est une réponse pédagogique une
réponse de professeurs qu'il faut
apporter et puis ceux qui consciemment
provoquent pour faire reculer la
République il ne faut plus que la
République recule il il y a un autre
risque don dont on voudrait parler dans
ce débat c'est le risque de banalisation
il y a eu la minute de silence hier dans
les écoles certaines et dans certaines
collectivités territoriales pas de grand
rassemblement euh ce ce weekend en
hommage à Dominique Bernard
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé il
y a 3 ans pour Samuel Patier est-ce que
vous parlez vous de banalisation écoutez
je vous propose avant de tirer une
conclusion d'analyser les faits et c'est
vrai que quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé en 2020 en octobre 2020 après la
décapitation de Samuel paatti et ce qui
s'est passé ce weekend relativement à
ton finalement après le meurtre du
professeur Daras c'est quand même le
contraste saisissant rappelez-vous en
octobre 2020 après le meurtre de Samuel
pati plusieurs manifestations sont
organisées un peu partout en France hein
à Bordeaux à Toulouse à Lyon mais
surtout surtout à Paris Thomas plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
étaient réunies place de la République
le dimanche qui a suivi le meurtre de
Samuel paatti et elles étaient là pour
défendre l'école laïque et aussi pour
bien sûr célébrer la mémoire du
professeur d'histoire geéographie de
donorine avec plusieurs responsables
politiques qui était présent oui parmi
eux le premier d'entre eux hein le
Premier ministre de l'époque Jean Castex
qui était là rappelez-vous aussi il
avait tweeté ce jour-là avec des mots
forts vous ne nous faites pas peur
avait-il dit nous n'avons pas peur vous
ne nous diviserez pas nous sommes la
France ce jour-là place de la République
Jean Castex était présent avec notamment
Marline chaper qui était ministre
délégué à la citoyenneté mais il y avait
aussi Jean-Michel Blanquer avec lui le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
place de la République ce jour-là il y
avait la maire de Paris annieidalgo la
présidente de la région île-de-fance
Valérie pcrè mais aussi le patron des
insoumis Jean-Luc Mélanchon qui était
venu défendre la laïcité et tous avaient
fait front commun en entonnant la
Marseillaise évidemment le contraste est
fort puisque 3 ans plus tard dans des
circonstances similaire pas de grandes
manifestations mais écoutez non
vraisemblablement ni les responsables
politiques ni les organisations
syndicales he NT souhaité organiser une
grande manifestation soir il y avait il
y a eu il y a eu des rassemblements tout
le weekend à l'initiative des des des
intersyndicales on a organisé après
juste pour finir on a appelé on a appelé
hier un rassemblement place de la
République à Paris moi j'ai vu beaucoup
de mes collègues je vous rejoins sur le
fait qu'il n'y avait pas autant de monde
qu' a qu' a 3 ans nous ce qui nous a
manqué dans ces rassemblements c'est le
soutien de la population c'est-à-dire
que moi hier à Paris j'ai vu beaucoup de
professeurs beaucoup de professeurs que
je connaissais par je connais du monde
en île- de- France mais je n'ai vu
quasiment personne qui ne soit pas
professeur de français ven il y avait il
y avait des politiques mais bon après ça
c'est leur leur démarche mais moi je
regrette par exemple qu'on a quasiment
pas vu de parents d'élèves on a
quasiment pas vu de citoyen et de
citoyens alors c'est vrai que moi je je
vous propose de conclure parce qu'il
faut conclure pourquoi ils ne sont pas
venus est-ce que comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure c'est la banalisation ou
est-ce que c'est encore plus fort que
cela Thomas est-ce qu'il y a une forme
de résignation face finalement à une
guerre un combat que l'on a accepté
finalement sur notre sol contre l'école
laïque comment expliquer que cette fois
la République n'a pas montré sa solidité
et puis sa solidarité avec les
enseignants on s'est senti très seul
hier soir place de la répu voilà vous
étiez très seul alors pourquoi c'est
c'est la question et l'absence de
manifestation après donc ce meurtre he
de Dominique Bernard nous amène à nous
poser collectivement pas uniquement les
enseignants cette question et le
politique doit se poser cette question
pourquoi parce que le politique doit il
a cette responsabilité de fédérer le
peuple français autour de l'école laïque
et républicaine Max Brisson votre avis
je je pense pas qu'il y a de résignation
mais je pense que les françaises et les
Français attendent maintenant autre
chose que des marches des minutes de
silence des moments de recueillement ils
sont nécessaires et nous les avons
multiplié au moment de l'affaire Samuel
pati mais à bien d'autres moments au
moment du Bataclan des attentats de Nice
nous avons face à l'islamisme radical
terroriste nous avons multiplié les
moments de recueillement pour faire
nation il faut le faire et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens attendent des réponses si
nous sommes en situation de guerre face
à l'islamisme radical il faut des
réponses qui armment notre République
pour répondre à cette guerre et pas
simplement je crois des moments de
recueillement c'est tout simplement ce
que les Français ressentent mais je ne
pense pas qu'il soit résignés pour
combattre ce qui est une barbarie
intrinsèque qui est le terrorisme
islamiste h votre avis làdessus Ismaël
Ferrat sur alors je sais pas quel mot
vous employez banalisation résignation
euh euh voilà ou ou alors peut-être je
reprends l'argument de de Max Brisson
euh peut-être qu'une partie des Français
disent bon bah oui on a suffisamment
manifesté maintenant il faut il faut
quoi aller au combat c'est quoi le
comment vous l'analysez ben déjà on peut
voir qu'il y a une forme de déclin c'est
que Charlie Hebdo manifestation
monstrueuse en France en janvier 2015
Samuel Patti manifestation assez
importante et qui dépasse effectivement
la communaé renseignantes et
effectivement pour notre collègue donc
Monsieur Bernard on se rend compte que
là c'est vraiment la communauté
enseignante qui se'est mobilisé les
organisations enseignantes et là il y a
espèce de de rétrécissement du noyau de
mobilisation je dire auprès des
collègues je dis vraiment voilà au sens
fort du terme je me de souligner qu'il y
a un autre événement qu'on a passé enfin
pas passé sous silence ce serait ce
serait pas le bon terme mais dont on n'
pas mesuré la gravité je pense que c'est
l'attaque de l'école juif en 2012 parce
que pour la première fois les islamistes
visvent une école et il y a quand même
deux piliers dans l'islamisme radical
c'est le le la détestation deoccident et
antisémitisme et à mon avis ce qui s'est
passé en 2012 oouvre en fait une
séquence où les islamistes disent voilà
on va vraiment tuer y compris enfin des
enfants faut quandême se rappel ce qui
s'est passé en 2012 dans une courte
d'école trois gosses à battu voilàépoque
la communauté juive avait été très
seulle ex et moi ça me rappelit un peu
l'affaire à en 2006 où là aussi
peut-être qu'on s'est pas rendu compte
de la gravité de ce qui se passait et
donc effectivement on est quand même au
3è enseignant tué en réalité en 10 ans
et il y a une espèce de continuité assez
terrible et mortifère dans dans cette
radicalité islamiste alors on va
terminer sur le le risque d'autoc
d'autocensure pardon vous l'avez évoqué
les uns et les autres mais je vous
propose un témoignage c'est le le
recteur de l'académie deex Marseille
hier lors de la minute de de silence
voilà il donne un peu la marche suiv on
l'écoute si un professeur se sent en
difficulté pour aborder tel point
d'histoire ou tel point de science euh
il doit venir vers nous on est là pour
aider les professeurs il n'est pas
question une minute de trouver une
quelconque défaillance il peut y avoir
des sujets extrêmement délicats à
aborder dans les différents thèmes de
l'histoire parfois de la géographie des
lettres euh mes quantités d'autres
domaines et le domaine scientifique et
nous nous devons être à côté de ces
professeurs selon l'ancien inspecteur
général de l'Éducation nationale
Jean-Pierre Aubin qui publie un livre
enquête sur la peur des des professeurs
80 % d'entre eux craignent des conflits
avec des élèves influencés par une
idéologie politicorigieuse Sophie
ventité cette proportion elle est elle
est un peu glaçante qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez 8 profs sur 10 ont peur alors
je sais pas je sais qu'il y avait eu des
des discussion sur sur l'enquête qu'
avait mené Jean-Pierre Aubin donc on va
pas c'est pas de de ça dont on va
discuter c'est aujourd'hui qui a des
professeurs qui s'interrogent ou qui se
qui se trouvent seul moi ce que
j'entends beaucoup c'est l'immense
sentiment de solitude des des
enseignants dans le dans dans le
contexte actuel face à tous les défis
qu'on nous demande de surmonter parce
qu'on demande quand même beaucoup de
choses à l'école et on demande parfois à
l'école de résoudre tous les problèmes
de la société et et dans cette solitude
il nous manque en fait les moments de
travail collectif de formation ensemble
les moments où on peut échanger entre
pères entre entre collègues et de ce
point de vuelà la question de la
formation continue c'est la formation
une fois qu'on est prof tout au long de
notre carrière c'est un moment décisif
il faut bien mesurer ce qui se passe en
ce moment Gabriel Attal a décidé de de
de mettre la formation continue en
dehors des heures de face- à face
pédagogique avec élèves donc pour faire
rapide le mercredi après-midi ou le ou
en début de soirée et parfois en visio
et donc on se retrouve avec par exemple
des formations sur la question de la
laïcité qui se font en visio de 18h à
20h en visio vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de faire des cas pratiques
avec vos collègues d'échanger moi je
sais que les formations sur la CIT celle
que j'ai pu suivre par exemple là où
c'était très intéressant c'est qu'on
avait des cas pratiques et on était tous
dans la même salle et on se disait bah
toi comment tu fais toi comment tu fais
et on échangeait et à la fin on partait
en se disant bon ben on sait un peu ce
qui se passe quand vous êtes en visio de
18h à 20h c'est extrêmement compliqué
donc la question vraiment des des
conditions de formation et de ce point
de vue là Gabriel Attal prend pas le bon
chemin elle va être déterminante merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vous dis à à bientôt sur
Public Sénat et je vous donne
rendez-vous demain 18h 22h pour un
nouveau sens public noté également sur
notre antenne l'invité de la matinale
demain ce sera Patrick canner le prés du
groupe socialiste au Sénat bonne
[Musique]
soirée